- Le départ est difficile.
Arielle Kayabagaeeee
l'hôtel de ville de London
et clôt le chapitre de
municipale.
chose que je connais très bien,
que j'ai beaucoup vécu
dans ma vie.
- Réfugiée burundaise
à 11 ans et mère de famille
monoparentale, le parcours
d'Arielle Kayabaga contraste
avec celui de beaucoup de
- C'est un cadeau que j'ai eu
de l'ancienne cons.....
- En 2018, elle devient
la première femme noire élue c .
Trois ans plus tard,
les électeurs de la même ville
choisissent de l'envoyer
à
le fédéral, le pas sera grand,
mais ccococococonnaissent
Arielle Kayabagane
ne s'inquiètent pas.
"Je pense qu'il n'y a pas
de limites pour elle, lance
le conseiller Jessyéyéyéyéyéyéya
depuis ses débuts en politique.
Pendant que la nouvelle députée
remplit ses dernières boîtes
et clôt ses derniers dossiers
àson bureau de circonscription,
son équipe s'active pour
faciliter la transition.
Les locaux sont petit,
et les ordinateurs ne sont
même pas tous branchés,
mais les bénévoles sont
Mazurek, qui explique que
beaucoup de ses amis se so
impliqués dans la campagne
d'Arielle.
ALEC MAZUREK, bénévole pour
la campagne d'yayayayayayabaga
- D'avoir une personne jeune
au Parlement, ça nous donne de
surtout maintenant dans
la polit
- À 31 ans, Arielle Kayabaga
inspire par son âge et
par ses origines. Sa victoire
en septembre a aussi interpellé
"J'ai pleuré quand j'ai appris
qu'elle avait gagné",
se souvient Gamal Tabidi, qui a
quitté le Soudan pour le Canada
Pour Arielle Kayabaga,
cette fierté de la c
génère une certaine pression.
ARIELLE KAYABAGA, députée, PLC
- Je ne suis pas toute
la communauté  s s s s s s suis
pas toute la communauté
des femmes, je ne suis pas toute
mais quand même, je peux amener
mon expéouououououououour
affecter les politiques.
- La politicienne se décrit
de gauche, une étiquette quipaps
femmes issues de la diversité
qui ont récemment claqué,,,,,,,,
comme Jody Wilson-Raybouldououo.
Arielle Kayabaga, libérale
de longue date, dit ne p
inquiète et promet de militer
pour plus d'inclusion
- Je n'ai pas encore rencontré
de barrières ou d
Je pense qu'on va pouvoir
ememememememememble
pour rectifier et pour changer
beaucoup de choses.
changements climatiques :yayayar
à de gros dossiers à Ottawa
tout en restant proche Elle a dn
de retourner dans son comté
une fois par semai-p-p-p-p-p-p-c
l'aide de son fils de 12 ans.
NOAH KAYABAGA, fils d'Arielle
- Je vais l'aider à chaque chose
qu'elle vaesesesesesesesesesese.
Elle aime aider les gens.
- Un soutien précieux pour
la nouvelle députée,
bieniqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqiqis
un long fleuve tranquille
et qu'il faudra faire face
à bien des intempéries.
adadadadadadadadadadadadadadada.